who's the most powerful company in the
world most people would probably say
Google Facebook ample or Amazon but what
if I told you that there was a singular
company behind all of these in fact this
singular company not only controls big
Tech but they actually control the
entire corporate world yet you've
probably never even heard their name
this company goes by the name sap and
they're the number one Enterprise
application provider in the entire world
they offer CRM Solutions SAS Solutions
sem Solutions and of course Erp
Solutions and virtually every company
that you can think of it relies on sap
for their back-end Solutions this
includes a 98 of the 100 most valuable
Brands 86 of the Fortune 500 and 92
percent of the Forbes 2000 and it's not
just corporations that depend on sap
either some of the most powerful
governments around the world are all
also rely on sap this includes the US
Canada India the UK France Australia and
many more Sap's customers are
responsible for 87 percent of the total
Global Commerce which works out to 46
trillion dollars considering this
stronghold on the Enterprise Market I
don't think you'd be surprised to hear
that by Nature sap also has a stronghold
on the consumer Market in fact 77 of the
entire world's transactional Revenue
goes through sap this translates to a
whopping 16 trillion dollars per year
with so much power you would think that
sap would be up to no good similar to
some of the financial Giants that also
run the world but somehow in their
50-year history sap has maintained a
relatively clean slate really the only
bad things that you can find about the
company are that they've had some
intellectual property lawsuits from
competitors and they've had a few cases
of bribery there's also a community that
thinks that sap software is overpriced
and not actually that good but that's
not an evil offense keep in mind sap
could literally blackmail the entire
world or run any company that they want
out of business so here's the story of
sap and how they became the most
powerful company that you've never heard
of
taking a look back the story of sap
dates back to the early 1970s ironically
to Xerox as you may know from one of our
previous videos Xerox basically invented
the computer the laptop the internet and
programming and gave it all away it
turns out that you can add sap onto that
list as well The Story Goes that when
Xerox exited the computer hardware
manufacturing industry in 1971. they
asked IBM to migrate their business
systems to IBM technology and to do this
Xerox offered IBM their rights to their
SDS sap software which was at the time
worth about 80 grand that's equivalent
to about 588 thousand dollars today five
German Engineers from IBM's AI
Department were initially assigned to
this project but due to some unknown
corporate reasons they would eventually
be switched to another project these
five Engineers however didn't want to
switch they had witnessed firsthand just
how much companies were willing to pay
to towards back in Solutions so instead
of switching to another IBM project as
instructed these five would quit IBM and
establish their own company called
system analysis and program development
or sap in June of 1972. their first
product was quite straightforward and
had to do with tracking it employee
Punch Cards IBM was the industry leader
within the sector so these five were
pretty familiar with their current
systems and their capabilities one of
the biggest shortfalls of the IBM punch
card system was that it recorded data
mechanically and every night someone
would have to process this data manually
for obvious reasons this was undesirable
and the sap aimed to eliminate this
hassle with their RF system unlike IBM
systems the RF system processed punch
card data electronically and
automatically store the data onto an
enterprise-wide database this made the
data easily accessible for anyone within
the organization whether it's the
accounting team or the payroll team
while this was convenient it also
required that the company maintain a
database this might be viable for
someone like IBM or Xerox but the local
Factory had no idea how to operate or
maintain a database so in addition to
the system sap also offered regular
maintenance and upgrades and this is
where the money was really at first this
was actually super easy given that there
was plenty of downtime these systems
were only used during the day Monday
through Friday so you could upgrade the
system during nights and on the weekend
but nowadays there isn't nearly as big
of a window given that downtime is
extremely expensive in the modern world
so sap has had to become quite creative
when it comes to maintenance and the
upgrades anyway sap would further refine
the system and create their first
Flagship product the sap R1 Sap's first
customer was a chemical company in
Germany but it didn't take them long to
onboard a bunch of local companies and
from there and didn't take long for sap
to become the go-to company for
all-in-one back-end Solutions
over the years sap has grown their
product line aggressively in fact they
currently offered 309 products but most
of this can be watered down into five
main categories starting with sap Erp or
sap enterprise resource planning this is
really the core of sap and it covers all
of the main functions that any business
would need this includes Supply Chain
management product lifecycle management
human Capital Management financial
management and customer relationship
management all of these accomplish
exactly what they sound like the Supply
Chain management software for example
helps companies keep track of inventory
analyze demand create projections of
Supply requirements manage Logistics and
so on similarly the financial management
software makes it easy to track
expenditures calculate taxes manage your
assets and ensure that you're compliant
with government regulations if a company
says that they're using sap they're
probably talking about one of their Erp
products if not it's more than likely
that they're talking about Sap's second
most popular offering which is sap
s4hana this is actually a relatively new
product from sap having been released in
2015. sap s4hana is basically just an
upgraded version of sap Erp and cxt with
more Advanced Technologies such as
parallel processing to make sap Erp more
efficient for larger corporations this
allows for SAP systems to operate on a
virtually real-time basis but if sap
s4hana is substantially better than sap
Erp when every corporation just used
s4hana well no because the better
performance comes along with a crop load
of extra responsibilities essentially
you need a bunch of In-House ID staff
that ensures that s4hana operates as
intended for companies like Apple and
Google who already have a bunch of IT
staff springing for this is a no-brainer
but for a company like Coca-Cola the
pitch isn't as appealing for companies
that don't want to do about bunch of
In-House management the most appealing
option may be saps for Hana Cloud this
offering is basically identical to sap s
for Hana except for one crucial
difference instead of running on
in-house databases and infrastructure
this runs on the cloud companies can
choose to deploy the software onto AWS
or Microsoft Azure this substantially
reduces the amount of Maintenance that
the companies have to do but in exchange
companies give up much of the
flexibility and customization that are
characteristic of the other offerings
moving on to the last two product
categories from sap we have sap business
1 and sap business by Design these are
essentially light versions of sap Erp
that are tailored to smaller businesses
sap business 1 for example is meant for
companies with up to 350 employees while
sap business by Design is meant for
companies with 250 to 1500 employees but
at the core of it these offerings
accomplish the same things just for a
different set of companies as you can
see it as sap basically covers all
business needs for all businesses so
it's not surprising that they're so
dominant within the industry
hearing all this you're probably
wondering at just how much all of this
costs
sap does post some pricing data for
their products but really every sap
deployment is handled on a case-by-case
basis especially for larger companies so
it's unlikely that any two companies pay
the exact same amount but here's a
ballpark estimate of what a company may
expect to pay the average Erp instance
uses about two to four terabytes the
average Honda deployment is supposed to
reduce this substantially if we assume a
50 reduction we get an instance of about
one to two terabytes according to
brightwork research this translates to
an upfront cost of 6.2 million dollars
along with an annual maintenance fee of
1.24 million dollars larger companies
can likely expect a pin up front V8 in
the tens of millions along with an
annual maintenance video of several
million dollars then that's just the fee
that you have to pay sap for most
deployments you need an in-house staff
and that this is very much true for the
juggernauts Amazon for example currently
has 42 openings for sap related roles
Google has 28 openings for sap and Apple
has 81 openings for sap and that's just
the open roles all of these companies
likely have several hundred if not over
a thousand full-time staff that just
maintain these systems and given that
Solutions Architects demanded quite a
high salary Erp likely costs these
companies at well into the hundreds of
millions if not billions every single
year but the truth is that there's no
way around this really the only other
options you have are to use Oracle who
charges the same amount or you can
develop your own inner system but
usually that's even more expensive not
to mention it it'll just distract the
company from being able to focus on
growing the core business so basically
every entity that you can think of end
up using sap Oracle or some combination
of the two given all this power you
would think that sap would be often no
good but as we discussed while there is
some discussion regarding whether sap
products are actually worth it or not
there's not much discussion regarding
the morality of the company as a whole
if anything it's actually the exact
opposite Sap's employees are extremely
happy with the company and its
leadership sap has a total of 26 000
reviews on Glassdoor with an average
rating of 4.4 Stars additionally 92
percent of employees would recommend sap
to a friend and at 91 percent approve of
the CEO on top of this 68 of employees
would not leave sap even if they were
offered more money and 83 percent are
excited to go to work every day clearly
sap is doing something right and that
this is reflected in their financials
sap regularly pulls in 30 billion
dollars per year and that they boast net
income of 4 billion dollars per year but
these numbers are nothing in comparison
to the true power that they hold
foreign
we often complain about X or Y company
being a monopoly and having too much
power but oftentimes some of the most
powerful companies are background
companies that we've never even heard of
sap isn't very much one of these
companies as they basically control all
of the business software used by the
entire world if this much power fell
into the wrong hands who knows what
would happen but so far sap has proven
to be very much qualified to handle this
responsibility and looking forward it it
doesn't look like sap is going anywhere
in fact if anything it seems like
companies are shifting from Oracle to
sap for greater flexibility and to avoid
oracle's Antics with intellectual
property so you better start keeping
tabs on sap because they're here to stay
and they're only growing stronger by the
day but that's just what I think were
you familiar with sap comment that down
below also drop a like if you hope that
sap gets some serious competition and of
course consider checking out our Discord
Community suggested video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and Aussie guys on the
next one